I said I wouldn't do my falls but we'll
see I'm getting a Brazilian wax my
girlfriend does get Brazilian waxes
often I think it'll be sort of like a
bonding experience really getting into
those crevices that typically never see
the light of day I want to get
everything ripped off I wanted our guard
go big or go home I heard that they're
supposed to like wax your balls it's
like a lot of light skin I think it's
gonna be painful I do have a date coming
up on Thursday and I'm hoping to not
have to bring up or share that this
happened hi I'm Jennifer I'm the owner
of the beauty strip in the know hole
Arts District
today we're doing a man zillion wedding
which is a Brazilian wax for men we wax
on the top of the bikini area we wax on
the side of the leg in the bottom of the
leg and then we also move in between the
cheeks and we cover the testicles as
well I've done thousands and thousands
of waxes I've seen lots of butt hole so
it is gonna be a great day all right so
we're gonna do
oh [ __ ] alright let's do it
[Music]
did you take the advil help you know do
you want to do in between your butt
cheeks as well yes Oh done good job yeah
you too
it's amazing better not sure
only without bad I heard you went all
out all out the waxer said I'll pull on
this in you pull on that in a scale of
one to ten how hairy were you guys going
in though I would say about a 12 oh [ __ ]
there was no nothing she pulled the
first remote whoa we're not counting now
here great I'm glad that it happened
what did you think the popsicles I
didn't know but I was like we we tapped
out honestly I don't think it was that
bad I do understand why women do it but
I'm not gonna do it again feel pretty
free you know feel pretty pretty uh
limber now like this there's nothing
there my girlfriend
absolutely loves the end result I think
I'm gonna do this again
[Music]